hello everyone and welcome to the first
game of the world church championship
2021 between magnus cross and and yani
palmishi magnus being the world champion
and nepo being the world champs
championship challenger uh we're gonna
uh cover all of the games that are gonna
be played it's 14 games
and the time format will be two hours
per player and no increment until move
60. so it's a bit of a different story
than when magnus faced the caruana or or
when he faced karjakin it is the
i think the same format that uh was used
in the vishwanathan anand versus magnus
calls and world championship match so
something that uh magnus is used to uh
so you can't really just let your time
go go down uh forever because you will
not have that 30 second increment you
know uh at the beginning when you make a
move so uh first 60 moves should be uh
sorry 40 not 60 moves first 40 moves
should be reached and then you will be
gaining uh some increment
after every move uh and also you will be
given an additional hour on the clock uh
so that being said uh let's check it out
this is game one already a very exciting
one uh let's see uh
let's see what they played and how how
it went so nipple with the white pieces
opens with e4
we have e5 by magnus so there was a lot
of discussion what um an apple will play
of course it's impossible to to figure
this out but e4 is very solid nipple is
a more of an aggressive player so uh
it does make sense for for him to go e4
but but i did mention in the previous
video uh that uh the only two world
championship games that magnus lost were
playing against the d4 and playing d4
himself so i thought maybe nepal was d4
but okay he went e4
e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and of
course bishop to b5 the rule lopez is on
the board with a6 uh magnus goes for
morphy's defense and bishop to a4 we
have knight to f6 and now neapo just
castles with bishop to e7 and rook to e1
uh so this is a very standard stuff
nothing out of the ordinary ordinary
here we see this pretty much every day
we have b5 bishop to b3 and here magnus
castles and now uh the the real question
here was will nipple play c3 and allow
magnus to go for the for the marshall
attack uh i was uh very much hoping for
this to happen but it did not nipple
played h3 sort of the uh the
anti-martial variation now we have
knight the a5 now and this is the real
uh surprise of the game uh usually what
people play here is just bishop to b7 or
d6 but here knight to a5 is very very
interesting i i don't know if if it's a
new move let me just check real really
quickly
uh
queen captures on d5 let me just check
this okay okay
there we go this is a new move all right
uh so here knight the a5 was played now
attacking the bishop here and
nipple didn't really take all that much
time to decide whether to capture on e5
or not he played knight captures on e5
saying that uh we kind of had this in
our preparation in our in our training
camp uh magnus captured on b3 we have
eight captures and bishop to be a
captures and bishop to b7 and here
magnus is down upon but he already has a
beautifully developed bishop his dark
square bishop is out his knight is out
uh whereas nipple only has a knight
developed on e5 and the rook on e1 so
magnus leading in development a little
bit but for the price of one pawn
we have d3 now as the e4 pawn is
attacked twice so we have to defend it
we have d3 by nipple and now magnus
immediately strikes in the center with
d5 so not allowing white to
consolidate uh
quickly we have e captures on d5 and now
queen captures on the five threatening
checkmate with queen captures and g2 uh
nipple played queen to f3 uh fairly
quickly and now comes bishop to d6 by
magnus putting more pressure on that
knight on e5 and now what do you play
here well you could trade queens but
that doesn't really give you all that
much and the problem is you can't really
play knight to c3 this is what uh
carlson's opening idea is is uh kind of
based on uh and it's very hard for white
to develop his pieces the problem with
knight the c3 is that we can play queen
captures an e5 and the white is just
lost you you've lost a piece and there's
no way of uh regaining it for example
rook captures on e5 we're gonna play
bishop captures on f3 and after we we
have to move the rook after something
like rook to e1 we move the bishop back
bishop to b7 and we're up a piece so we
have a light square bishop white doesn't
so nipple again finds a move very
quickly here he plays king to f1 and it
is now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game uh
there are a couple of positions where
queen capture sandify was played but
this is uh a new move and it's a very
interesting one apple found it very
quickly so probably he had it in his
home preparation at some point uh now
the the thing is a little bit different
um
because if you go for queen captures on
e5 now uh or rather
after king to f1 uh uh rook f2 b8 was
played but uh if you play queen captures
on e5 now well then queen captures on b7
is an option because now for example
queen to h2
isn't uh isn't all that troublesome
queen back to f3 we're going to play
queen h1 check king to e2 uh looks
terrible but it works rook f38 to check
and we're just gonna block with the
bishop to e3 with black's queen uh
hanging on h1 so he's gonna have to move
it we're gonna play king to d1 and we've
sort of castled and uncastled uh but uh
you know it works and the black didn't
really achieve all that much he's down
upon and white is very happy with his
position so instead of this queen
captures an e5 we have uh
rook back to b8 by magnus and now what
do you play uh well here we have queen
captures on the e5 and this is basically
forced um it's uh hard to you know make
make a
different move here because again if you
play knight to see three queen captures
on e5 is the same uh the the rook is now
guarding the bishop there's not much you
can do rook captures an e5 bishop
captures an f3 and after we move the
rook bishop to c6 or something again
it's the same thing so here nipple
trades we have queen captures on d5
knight captures on d5 and now we have
bishop to d2 again it's not easy for uh
for nipple to develop his pieces here uh
because you you want to play that knight
the c3 move but if you play this then
this knight to b4 is is a real problem
uh because your bishop is still here you
don't have the option of placing the
rook on c1 to defend the the c2 pawn and
well rook to e2 it just looks very
clumsy
white's position would be very bad here
so here we have bishop
at the d2 uh waiting with this move but
also freeing up the c1 square for the
rook
uh to use if knight to b for his played
uh we have c5 by magnus again played
played fairly quickly and now knight to
f3 uh neopo just retreats the knight uh
when knights the c3 again can be played
now for example if knight of b4 we can
place rook the rook to c1 with the pawn
being defended and it's uh it's a
playable position uh but nipple decides
to go back knight to f3 and now magnus
really went into um
not too too deep of a thing but but a
pretty big thing uh and after 20 minutes
he played rook to d8 uh interestingly uh
if you go knights to b for
now uh you're kind of inviting bishop
captures on b4 and this will double your
pawns but it uh appears that this will
not be good for white because if this
happens for example captures captures uh
what do you play here now now this is a
backward spawn it's going to be very
hard to defend it for example knight b
to d2 we're going to play rook to c8
attack the pawn and after something like
94 we attack the bishop bishop to f8
you're going to have to defend it with
something like rook a to c1 or rook to
a2 but this is a permanent weakness so
it would it wouldn't be all that
pleasant for white to go after this so
the point is after knight to b4 white
can't really capture here you're going
to have to play something like rook the
c1 and this would be
the position that would probably arise
on the board it looks very nice for
black with uh you know white's pieces
being placed very clumsy uh but uh
magnus decided against it so after
knight to f3 he went rook back to d8
like i said after thinking for some 20
minutes
and now we have knight to c3 finally
nipple plays this move and now he offers
magnus this b for a square uh
interestingly the the engine gives king
to e2 is also a very nice uh
resource just shifting the king to d1
and you no longer have to worry about
your c2 pawn so uh castling and on
castling is definitely a thing so after
rook to d8 we have knight to c3
like i said and now knight to b4 putting
pressure on this c1 pawn c2 pawn and the
question is will nipple defend this with
rook 8 to c1 or with the rook e to c1 so
both uh moves have their merits but you
have to decide on one and apple plays a
rook e to c1 so he keeps the rook on the
a file
uh as well it's a it's a semi-open files
so uh he he decided uh he decided to
keep it there even though the e file is
a fully open file so you know it also
makes sense to keep the rook there but
of course uh he has his reasons uh and
here we just have rook eight to c8 by
magnus and now the situation on the
clock is some one hour and 12 minutes
for nipple and an hour and 26 minutes
for magnus
and here we have knight to e2
interestingly it's kind of possible to
offer a draw here with knight to a2 just
saying okay let's trade knights and if
knight c6 knight back to c3 knights to
be for knight a2 but you know if you've
come all the way to dubai to do this
then well maybe you shouldn't have come
at all but okay after rook 8 to c8 we
have knights to e2 now again in control
of this f4 square so probably bishop to
f4 is the plan but also just freeing up
this c3 square so we can play maybe c3
at some point uh here we have knight
back to c6 by magnus now you could
continue with something like bishop to
f8 also you want to free up this uh uh d
file for the rook uh and now again if
bishop captures and b for c captures
it's uh i mean it looks great for black
it's also not bad for white so uh it can
be played let's say d4 here
and it's uh it's a pretty pretty uh
funky position at some point the bishop
might be able to come to e4 attack that
c2 pawn
but
of course many things can be played here
at some point in the official commentary
well there's no basically official
commentary there are many uh official
commentaries now um it's uh
uh it it's been said that um
uh well you you could uh just uh you
know uh play like this but it's uh
it's hard because at some point your
position will just deteriorate you you
play a move and then your opponent makes
a move to counter that move you play
move your opponent makes a move to
counter that move and at some point you
just um
find yourself in a terrible position and
something similar did happen in the game
just not in this position so here we
have knight to c6 magnus goes back he
wants to bring the knight to e7 then to
g6 and then
possibly to f4 this would be very good
for him so bishop to e3
and now comes knight to e7 and here
finally we have this bishop to f4 move
interestingly you could also play
knights the g3 here uh it looks very
ugly because you can capture on f3 you
can capture on g3 but none of this is
all that great for black black is down
upon and his real uh
plus side here is that he does have the
fully operational bishop pair so
capturing here uh wouldn't really be all
that impressive you now white has the f2
square for his king and you've uh
eliminated
any possibility of bishop captures an f3
ever being a threat because now you're
just gonna undouble white spawns uh but
okay after knight e7 we have bishop to
f4 nipple goes for this trade now even
though some other moves could have been
considered but uh you know it's such a
such a dry position uh where any move
can be considered and it doesn't really
give you all that um uh you know much
advantage so here finally we have bishop
captures and f3 now magnus gives up the
bishop for this knight but it comes with
a with a good idea bishop captures on f3
g captures the bishop captures on f4
knight captures and now rook the c6 as
now white has some weaknesses here uh
rook can come to f6 put some pressure on
these weaknesses or maybe even to h6 to
put pressure on the h3 pawn now if you
look at the position white is still up
upon but he does have three pawn islands
white has two pawn islands and it will
be a little bit easier for black to
attack those pawns if the rooks
ever ever get into the game could be
very dangerous
uh so here rook back to e1
attacking the knight on e7 and knight to
f5 this is what carlson wanted to do uh
either way and now finally we play c3
we
we prepare to uh push some pawns in the
center uh but also it's a it's a very
useful uh move to prevent for example
this knife from coming to d4 and later
on maybe we can even play c4 and put our
own knight on d5 uh so here how do you
continue well it seems like you could
just kick away this knight and win the
d3 pawn but if you played this
then rook to e5 can be played and now of
course you're not going to move your
knight you're going to attack your
opponent's knight and after g captures
rook captures you're going to capture on
d3 by white will capture on f4 and we
have uh well both players have
three pawn islands two two rooks each
there's not much to be done here so
instead after c3 we have knight to h for
by magnus putting pressure on the f3
pawn we have rook to e3 and now
comes the moment where you have to
decide what to do and it's a very tricky
position and the best move in the
position is pawn to g6 simply preparing
this knight to f5 move uh because if the
knight comes to f5 to attack the rook
yes you want to remove this rook and
grab the d3 pawn uh white can always
play rook to e5 and attack that knight
the g6 prevents this and now knight to
f5 is a pretty big threat but magnus
decided to play king to f8 instead uh
sort of improving the the the position
of his king uh and now it seems like uh
the the the same idea can still be
played but nepo or rather magnus thought
that nepal did not have a useful move
here because it's not very easy for him
to move his pieces uh but he does have
this very annoying knight to g2 move and
now
magnus really has to decide uh what to
do here again trading knights that's uh
you know
they can agree to a draw that's not uh
you know a lot of fun so magnus does go
back with knight to f5 now attacks the
rook but now comes the move that we've
discussed and the black is really
missing that g6 move so rook to e5
attacks the knight so you don't have
time to grab the d3 pawn g6 now and now
not even rook to d1 but rather knight to
e1 attacking this uh uh d3 pawn uh we
have knight to g7 and now comes rook to
e4 again uh a very tricky position the
best move probably for white is to just
advance the doubled uh f pawn and then
we'll just prepare f5 especially since
black is getting ready to play knight to
e6 if he does this now then we can play
f5 and well this is now
really good for white
for example knight to f4 we're gonna go
after the h3 pawn but now we're just
gonna play f captures on g6 and after h
captures rook back to e3 regarding this
regarding this twice so
nowhere is there so this is something
that nipple could have gone for but
instead he played rook to e4 and now
it's a little bit easier for for magnus
to counter this idea and he finds it on
the spot he plays f5
attacks the rook and you have to
go back if you play something like rook
to h4 to put pressure on this pawn you
might even blunder your rook for example
g5 attacks the rook and now what do you
play here all of these squares are taken
by by uh magnus's pawns so you're gonna
have to capture here and then just king
here and uh well you lose uh that rook
because knight covers this pawn covers
this real covers this and that's it you
have to give up the rook and you're
gonna lose this game
so instead after f5 we have rook back to
e3 and now comes knight to e6 the knight
of course has to come to f4 there the
knight will be a monster since nipple
does not have a
e pawn or a g pawn to kick it away from
f4 and now uh here after knight to e6 we
have knight to g2 uh and uh this is uh
uh what uh what i said that uh uh anish
geary mentioned in the live commentary
that all of the moves that white made
were uh
aimed at countering black's ideas of
course the rook is needed here to
prevent rook captures and d3 the knight
is needed here to prevent the knight
this knife from coming to the f4 uh but
now magnus shifts the attention over to
the queen side and pushes the absolute
strongest moving chess and that of
course is pawn to b4 and now now you
have you have some problems here you
can't really react to this of course you
you never want to capture if you capture
then this is just terrible uh
there's really no no no reason to do
this you have four pawn islands you have
two doubled pawns the this is just the
bad so nipple of course finds the
probably the best idea that is king to
e2 you have to go help out with the king
and now rook to b8 what magnus is now
threatening is c b captures in c three b
captures and then he wants to win his
pawn back uh retaining a more active
position uh we have king to d2 uh if you
try and keep the pawn for example with
rook to b1 that's just going to end very
badly we're going to play a5 and now
what do you do for example king to d2
we're going to play b captures and c3 b
captures and a4 and now the rook on b1
is is a pretty big problem
and the other lines really don't help so
instead after rook to b8 we have king to
d2
and now we have b captures b captures
and rook captures on b3 and now with
some threats of maybe rook to b2 check
so we have to counter this king to c2 by
nipple and now we have rook back to b7
the problem with doubling up on the b
file is uh the knight on e6 nipple can
just capture here and that's it yeah
you're lost if you capture the rook
where you're going to lose the rook on
b3 and even rook b2 checking the c1 you
don't have a good continuation here uh
and you're just uh down down a knight so
instead after king to c2 attacking the
rook magnus goes back rook to b7
and now nipple plays h4 a very useful
move not allowing magnus to just freely
advance those pawns on the king side and
maybe even later on you can you can
undermine this pawn structure with a
move like h5 and now what do you play
here well this knight to d4 check move
looks very interesting but it doesn't do
all that much the problem is after
knight to d4 check of course you're not
going to capture this if you capture
then it's just game over it's check you
go here to defend the rook now even rook
b2 check comes and after king d1 we can
just play captures now if you capture
with the knight then we can you know
capture the pawn so uh or rather if you
capture with the pawn we can capture the
knight so you have to capture with the
knight and it's just a very very bad
you're down the exchange and your
position is terrible so instead
after knight the d4 check you would have
to play king to d2 and then your
position
oh sorry after knight you would have to
play king to d1 and then your position
is you know just fine there's nothing to
worry about the knight is just silly
there and the knight has to go back so
that's why
it wasn't played magnet started with
king to f7
and now comes rook e back to e1 now the
king guards the pawns here and you don't
need a rook on e3 as
it's a very passive square for the rook
king to f6 by magnus and now knight to
e3 and now nipple wants to bring this
knight to c4 and there it will be a
powerful piece uh and now uh magnus here
uh had to decide what to play uh knight
to f4 seems like a very promising move
uh as it's a it's a very active knife
for example knight to c4 we're going to
play rook to e7 now challenge the rook
here and after this maybe okay knight
back to e3
um
asks what do you play here now this
knight can't really move because knight
d5 check with the win win the exchange
here so we're gonna play rook to d6 and
then uh keep the
uh keep the position alive however in
the game rook the d7 was played by
magnus uh and uh also by playing rook to
d7 they've reached move 40 so they've
reached time control additional time was
it was given to them they both now got
an extra hour on the clock uh but nepo
just played knight to c for here and
this is a
uh well a very annoying move because
it's hard to
it's hard to make progress here with
black uh what do you play here that's
the question the e5 square is very weak
if knight to e5 is played then you're
going to lose the exchange so you're
going to have to play something like
rook to d8 which is not a move that you
want to play uh instead a magnus played
rook to e7 but rook the e7 is basically
an invitation to a draw
and uh well nippo decided to to grab
this um opportunity we have knight to e5
attacking the rook now you can't move
the rook away from the sixth rank
because of rook captures on a6 so rook
to d6 was played knight to c for rook to
c6 knight to e5 rook to d6 and knight to
c4 and he was in this position on move
45 that magnus and ifo agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
like i said uh it's uh
you can't move the rook because this
pawn falls and the white uh well white
uh really does not have any any active
play uh of his own to to go for in you
know yeah instead of this repetition
so uh what do you guys think about game
one uh i think it was uh it was a fairly
interesting uh you know at the end game
not so much but but the beginning and
the opening choice uh i did enjoy it's
not as crazy as the one that uh
crossing and caruana played in 2018 in
london that lasted over seven hours and
there's you know there were so many uh
crazy moments where where i think magnus
even had a win at some point but it was
uh too uh too ambitious to to go for for
such an idea uh but here uh the i think
the finest moment of the of the game is
this move 14 uh after bishop to d6 uh
you know threatening all sorts of nasty
ideas that nipple just played king to f1
and he said none of this works now my
position is fine
and you know the game just continues so
magnus gave upon very early on in the
game he got a fully operational bishop
pair for it and then uh maybe maybe that
one point where he uh could have uh
played it a little bit better but you
know it's it's hard to say because this
is classical chess all of these uh lines
have been uh thoroughly crunched by
their teams by all the engines they're
using and it's hard to say if you know
it would mean all that much here instead
of this king to f8 i just prepared this
with the g6 and now knight to f5 is a
pretty uh pretty nasty um
move to face it it's hard to uh
it's hard to counter this move after g6
it's uh
uh white white doesn't really have a
good reply to this at some point he he
will have to give back the pawn but he
will probably have to give back the pawn
in in any lines like in the line that he
played uh the the engine gives c4 as a
very interesting move here that point
being that if now you go knight to f5 we
can play rook to e5
uh and now if rook captures on d3 then
of course we can just capture this rook
so that's uh
or rather after rook captures on d3 we
can just capture this rook so uh we
can't play that but let's say king to g7
and now now the game continues so maybe
maybe something
maybe something in in those lines uh but
yeah very very exciting i'm sure after
the the first game their teams will have
a lot to do and they will not go to
sleep early as you know the position
might repeat in game three where uh
magnus will again have the black pieces
nipple will again have the white pieces
and they have to be ready for uh any and
all improvements uh uh that are possible
uh so yeah that's game one of the world
chess championship 2021 hope you guys
enjoyed that we're going to be covering
all of the games so so stay tuned for
that i would like to thank eduardo j
pagwaga business coach academy please
like and subscribe again supankar and
david kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
cheers championship 2021
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day